in the last video we had a word problem
where we had
we essentially had to figure out the
sides of a triangle but instead of you
know just being able to do the
pythagorean theorem and and because it
was a right triangle it was just kind of
a normal triangle and then it wasn't a
right triangle and we just kind of chug
through it using sohcahtoa and just our
very simple trig
functions and we got the right answer
what i want to do now is introduce you
to something called the law of cosines
which we essentially
proved in the last video but i want to
kind of prove it in a more you know
without the word problem getting in the
way and i want to show you once you know
the law of cosines you can then apply it
to a problem like we did in the past and
you'll do it faster i i have a bit of a
a mixed opinion about it because i'm not
a big fan of memorizing things you know
when you're when you're 40 years old you
probably won't have the law of cosines
still memorized but if you have that
ability to start with the trig functions
and just move forward then you'll always
be set
and and i'd be impressed if you're still
doing trigger 40 but but who knows so
let's go and let's and let's see what
this law of cosines is all about
so let's say that i know
this angle theta
i know this angle theta
and i know let's call this side
i don't know
a
let's call this side b
i'm being a little arbitrary here
let's call that oh actually let me let
me stay in the colors of the
of the side so that way let's call that
b
and let's call
let's call this
c
and then let's call this side a
so if this was a right triangle then we
could have used the pythagorean theorem
somehow but well now now we we can't
so what do we do so we know a well let's
fight let's let's assume that we know b
we know c we know theta and then we want
to solve for a but in general we can you
know if as long as you know three of
these you can solve for the fourth and
once you know the law of cosines so how
can we do it well we're going to do it
the exact same way we did that last
problem
we can drop
a line here
to make oh my god that's messy i thought
i was using the line tool
edit undo
undo
so i can drop a line like that i'm
trying to make it so i have two right
angles
and then once i have right triangles and
now i can start to use trig functions
and pythagorean theorem etc etc so
so let's see so this is a right angle
and this is a right angle
so what is what is this side here what
is
what is
let me pick another color i'm probably
going to get too involved with all of
the colors but
it's for your improvement so what is
this side here what is the length of
that side that purple side
well that purple side
is just you know we use sohcahtoa i
always it's good to write sohcahtoa up
here so
so this purple side is adjacent to theta
and then this blue or mole side b
is
is uh is the hypotenuse right of this
right triangle so we know that i'm going
to stick to one color because it'll take
me forever if i keep switching colors
we know that cosine of theta
let's call this side let's call this
kind of subside let's call this
i don't know let's call this d
side d
we know that cosine of theta is equal to
d
over
b right and we know b
or
that d
is equal to
what it equals
b
cosine
theta
now let's call this side e
right here
e
well what's e well e is this whole c
side
c side oh that's it this whole c side
minus this d side right so e
is equal to c minus d
we just solved for d so side e
is equal to c
minus
b cosine of theta
so that's e we got e out of the way
and what's this magenta side going to be
well let's call this magenta let's call
it m for magenta
m
well m is opposite to the to theta and
so if we what what involves well we
could now we know we've solved for c as
well but we know b and b is simple so
what relationship gives us m over b
or involves the opposite and the
hypotenuse well that's sine opposite
over hypotenuse
so we know that
m over b is equal to sine of theta
we know that
let me go here
m
over b right because it's hypotenuse is
equal to
sine
of theta
or
that m
is equal to
b
sine
of theta right so we figured out m
we figured out e and now we want to
figure out a and this should jump out at
you we have two sides of a right
triangle we want to figure out the
hypotenuse we can use the pythagorean
theorem
this pythagorean theorem tells us a
squared is equal to
m squared plus
e squared right just the square of the
other two sides
well what's m squared plus e squared let
me switch to another color just to be
arbitrary
so a squared
is equal to m squared m is b sine of
theta so it's
b
sine
of theta squared
plus
e squared well e we figured out is this
so it's plus
c
minus b cosine
theta squared now let's just chug
through some algebra so that equals
b
sine
b squared sine sine squared theta sine
squared theta just means sine of theta
squared right
plus and let me just foil this out i
although i don't like using foil i just
multiply it out but
c squared
minus
c
b
cosine
theta
plus
b squared
cosine theta right i just expanded this
out by multiplying it out
and now let's see if we can do anything
interesting well if we take this term
and this term
we get
that those two terms are b squared
sine
squared of theta plus b squared
cosine that should be a distribute
squared there right because we squared
it b squared cosine squared of theta
and then we have plus
c squared
minus 2
b c cosine
theta
well what does this simplify to well
this is the same thing as
this equals b squared times the sine
squared
theta plus cosine squared of theta
something should be jumping out at you
and that's
plus the c squared minus 2 b c
cosine of theta
well this thing cosine
sine squared plus cosine squared of any
angle is is one that's that's one of the
earlier identities that's just you know
that's the pythagorean identity right
there so this equals one so then we're
left with
we're left with going back to my
original color we're almost there
a squared
is equal to
this term just becomes one so b squared
we're just left with a b squared
right
plus c squared
minus
b c cosine
of theta
that's that's pretty neat and this is
called the law of cosines
and it's it's useful because you know if
you know an angle and two of the sides
of of any triangle you can now solve for
the other side
and and or really if you want to if you
know three sides of a triangle you can
now solve for any angle so that also is
very useful
the only reason why i'm a little bit you
know here there is i don't
it is good if you are in trigonometry
right now and you might have a test you
should memorize this because it'll make
you faster and you'll get the answer
right quicker i'm not a big fan of of
just memorizing it without knowing where
it came from because
a year from now or two years from now
when you go to college and you're it's
been four years since you took
trigonometry
you probably won't have this memorized
and if you face a trig problem all of a
sudden it's good to kind of get there
from scratch
with that said this is the law of
cosines and if you use the law of
cosines you could have done that problem
we just did a lot faster because we just
you know you just have to set up the
triangle and then just substitute into
this and you could have solved for a in
that ship off course problem i'll see
you in the next video